i'm going to talk a little bit about how
we made the first picture of a black
hole
scientists have been studying black
holes ever since they were first
predicted
from einstein's theory of general
relativity just over 100 years ago
and in particular for decades scientists
have been studying the giant elliptical
galaxy
at the head of the virgo constellation
so this galaxy which is called m87
is really special it's 55 million light
years away from us
and over 100 years ago someone
discovered this streak of light on the
sky
and it ended up being this galactic
scale jet of plasma that was shooting
out of the core of the galaxy
and marking the spot of a supermassive
black hole so over
decades scientists tried to develop
better and better instruments
telescopes to try to study the black
hole predicted to be at its center
and then in april of 2017 we hooked up
this earth's ice telescope
and collected the data necessary to make
the first image of a black hole
and two years later after processing the
data this is what we saw
and this black hole image was the result
of a group of hundreds of astronomers
physicists
mathematicians engineers from all around
the world
who are working together to achieve
something that wouldn't have been
possible for any one person to do
so the first question you might ask is
how are we able to take a picture of a
black hole that by definition doesn't
let light escape
but light propagating near a black hole
actually doesn't follow straight lines
space and time are actually curved by
the black hole's gravity
and this means the light can even go in
complete circles around it
so some of this light is falls into the
black hole but other ones just
graze it it's bent around it so that the
net effect is essentially that the black
hole casts the shadow
on a backdrop of hot material that's
almost perfectly circular
um and this ring is referred to as a
black hole shadow because it's like the
imprint of the black hole on all this
hot gas behind it
this is what astrophysicists think a
black hole would actually look like up
close
this ring is really really tiny it's
about 40 microarch seconds in size
which is about the same size as a grain
of sand but when that sand
is in boston and i'm viewing it from
here in california
so it's like you held up a grain of sand
at mit and
i had to try to see it from here in
california and so taking a picture
of something that small is really hard
the reason why it can all be explained
with a very simple equation
diffraction says that there are
fundamental limits to the smallest
objects we can see
just like our eyes can't see like
bacteria and different things like this
uh telescopes also have fundamental
limits of what they can see
and this governing equation says that in
order to see smaller and smaller
we have to make our telescope bigger and
bigger so if we plug in the size of the
black hole we want to see and the
wavelength we have to see it at we can
easily calculate that we just need to
build a telescope
13 million meters across or essentially
the size of the earth
and if we could build this earth-sized
telescope we could just start to make
out that ring of light that's indicative
of the black hole's event horizon
well okay obviously building a single
dish telescope the size of the earth
isn't possible but by joining telescopes
located around the world
i've been working as part of an
international collaboration
called the event horizon telescope that
built a computational telescope
the size of the earth that was capable
of resolving structure on the scale of a
black hole event for heisen
for the very first time so how does this
computational telescope work
well a radio telescope is they act
essentially just like giant mirrors
light from the black hole it's going to
travel the earth for 55 million years
and then it's going to bounce off that
dish and collect at the focal point here
and all the light is going to collect at
that one location
but now let's imagine that instead of
building a single
earth-sized dish instead we laid mirrors
all across the earth
essentially turning the earth into a
giant spinning disco ball
well then we could collect the light at
each one of these tiny little mirrors
record the light that we see at each
location and then we could combine the
individually collected light in a
computer
to make a picture just as good as the
original one that we could get with a
single
mirror but what happens if we remove
most of these mirrors so only a few
remain
well that's exactly what the event
horizon telescope has to deal with
so all of the researchers in the
worldwide network work together
so so once we have gotten these tiny
little signals
then this question remains of how do we
make a picture right
how do we form a picture from all this
data because we only have telescopes at
a few locations
that means we only get a small number of
measurements and so
what are these measurements you can
think of them each one as being notes in
a song
so watching the black hole with the
event horizon telescope is a bit like
listening to a song being played on a
piano that has a lot of broken keys
if you were able to recognize the song
what you're doing is your brain is
filling in the holes to kind of tell you
what you're listening to
so this is really similar to how we
dealt with making an image of the black
hole
we designed algorithms that would use
the sparse data we collect and they
would fill in the missing notes to try
to reconstruct the underlying black hole
image
and then after seven weeks we all
gathered together in cambridge
massachusetts
and we revealed the images to each other
and this is what we saw
a ring of roughly the same size that was
brighter on the bottom than the top
this image tells us so much about the
immediate environment around a black
hole
but perhaps one of the most amazing
things is that by comparing this picture
to simulation scientists have made for
years
stimulations that predict what the
emission around the black hole would
look like assuming einstein was right
about gravity
we find that the image we took was
amazingly consistent with the number of
these predictions and so
by studying this image we have the best
evidence as of yet that black holes
exist
as well as a way to study and learn
about the immediate environment around a
black hole
how the matter falls onto them and how
they impact their galaxies around them
so i hope going forward you have the
chance to work with some amazing people
go in
unexpected directions and do something
that you also thought wasn't possible
you